друзі Всіх вітаю це Верховна Рада
України
це пленарний тиждень і його ви не
побачите на каналі Рада в Марафоні адже
там діяльність парламента не
висвітлюється хоч на це виділяється 200
млн грн і вони йдуть на офіс президента
Отже 8 листопада єврокомісія
рекомендувала розпочати переговори про
вступ України і Молдови до Європейського
Союзу день який ми чекали як мінімум 10
років день коли з 14-го року коли тисячі
людей мільйони людей вийшли на Майдан
вимагаючи інтеграції України в
Європейський союз коли були підписані
мною угоди про асоціацію угода про
безвізовий режим угода про поглиблену і
всеохоплюючу зону вільної торгівлі І от
зараз через декілька годин після
колегіуму Європейська комісія має
приймати висновок який відкриває дорогу
переговорному процесу вступу України в
Європейський союз і от ви знаєте коли я
побачила цю інформацію з брюселю що є
таке важливе історичне рішення взяла
слово аби сказати і привітати з цим
український парламент цей шлях
розпочався 10 років тому коли Янукович
відмовився відмовився
підписуватиціацію і тоді герої Майдану
насправді розпочали цей шлях я дякую і
нинішньому парламенту і попередньому
парламенту за те що ми з вами разом
голосуємо всі законопроекти і виконуємо
ті завдання які необхідні для історичної
місії нашої вступу України до ЄС
очевидно що в цьому парламенті відсутна
політична культура історична пам'ять і
це дуже сумно нам потрібно посилювати
інституційну спроможність парламенту і
дотримуватися копенгагенських критеріїв
які визначають насправді фундамент
європейських країн а це і свобода слова
це і демократія це і сильна
децентралізація все те що руйнується в
сучасній Україні і от 8 листопада
парламент проголосував в повторному
другому читанні скандальний законопроект
137 яким перерозподіляє ПДФО військове з
громад до спецфонду в центрі начебто з
благими намірами для начебто закупівлі
Дронів і виробництва снарядів Але є одне
але по-перше цей закон вступає в силу
заднім числом з 1 жовтня 23го року як
можна заднім числом забрати кошти Ну як
як це можна зробити може ви цього ще не
знаєте зима починається хто буде
опалювати наші міста хто ті хто зараз
голосують за те щоб забрати ці гроші хто
буде нести відповідальність нам вже
кажуть найстрашніша зима так що ж ви
робите дфо військових ішли на конкретні
підрозділи громади направляли їх на
закупівлю Дронів тепловізорів колес
машин всього чого так не вистачає
сьогодні в підрозділах військових і ми
бачимо що зараз це все буде ну значно
ускладнено через місцеве самоврядування
швидкість
отримання допомоги бригадами складає дні
максимум тижні якщо ви проголосуєте цей
закон це будуть місяці всі мінімум 5-ш
місяців очевидно що це наступ на
децентралізацію ви знаєте як цей закон
називають в народі називають закон про
забрать ви знаєте що це є
похорон
похорон самоврядуванню реформі
децентралізації і я пишаюся тим що для
нашої команди Це світ визнав Це була
найбільш успішна реформа якщо
виділяються кошти начебто на закупівлю
Дронів і виробництво снарядів Чому вони
ідуть не на Міністерство оборони а в
якийсь спецфонд е в службу спецзв'язку
яка навіть не є розпорядником коштів
друзі якщо би це все забирались для того
щоб повернути тридцятку для того щоби
виплатити гроші
е виведеним поза штат пораненим Та ні це
все забирається щоб роздеребанити в
Києві бо вже не вистачає те що було вже
роздеребанили треба роздеребанити
залишок що того що є місцевого
самоврядування ми боролися за те аби
пройшли наші поправки аби цей
законопроект ну був прийнятий в
компромісному варіанті аби 10%
залишилися
на фортифікаційні споруди на регіони на
громади повністю невраховані інтереси
громад які знаходяться на лінії фронту
чи на прифронтових територіях повністю
ви забираєте в них гроші і за замість
того не пропонуєте реально нічого вони
мають іти на поклон до Києва але нічого
не почула Влада ви просто грабуєте і
нищити місцевего самоврядування ваша
коаліція ми її бачимо колеги не
доєднуйтесь до коаліції слуга народу
опзж і частина голосу ну це ганебно бути
в такій коаліції разом голосувати за
такий ганебний закон ще кілька дуже
важливих рішень які парламент ухвалив 8
листопада Це закон уже про спрощений
порядок отримання убд і оце є приклад
єдності і відповідальності парламенту
коли ми знаходимо аргументи знаходимо
механізми і робимо все для того щоби
прискорити вирішити питання про убд і
дуже важливо що ми зробили перший крок
за ініціативою європейської солідарності
взагалі до автоматичного отримання ОБД
порядок існує
зараз круги
пекла маємо індивідуально подавати
замовлення командир батальйона потім
командир бригади потім завершення папі
папірцевої роботи потім комісія потім
все для того щоби засвідчити воїн воює
бере участь в бойових діях і захищає
Україну адже сьогодні в Україні вже
більше 1 мільна воїнів тільки 15% їх
отримали статус учасника бойових дій я
запропонував кардинально інше рішення
автоматично без бюрократичної процедури
за поданням командира бригади лише тих
Хто відданий в брку бойове розпорядження
Ми включаємо зараз список Уявіть собі
850 000 українських військовослужбовців
які мають на це право ще в травні цього
року парламент прийняв важливий закон
про створення національного військового
кладовища але він і досі не підтриманий
президентом не підписаний президентом і
от слуги хотіли перенести місце
кладовища національного з биківні до
Гатного Шановні колеги поясніть будь
ласка А що ми розглядаємо як парламент
дійшов до такого самоприниження нагадую
в травні ми ухвалили закон про ві
меморіальне кладовищеа 322 голоси всі
фракції всі Міністерства всі підтримали
майже той самий текст який ми
розглядаємо сьогодні окрім місця
розташування Звичайно Це відбувалося без
урегулювання з родинами загиблих
керівництво Верховної Ради і
керівництво фракції слуга народу обіцяли
зустрітися з родинами загиблих для того
щоби проговорити з ними це чутливе
питання почуйте обуре родичів загиблих
героїв які вже скликали прес-конференцію
які ініціювали петицію до президента з
вимогою підписати закон про
кладовище колеги парламент не має права
бути ширмою для цієї
своволі закон ухвалений ми маємо вже
зробити все щоб герої поховані були і
отримали своє національне військове
кладовище досить знущатися над родинами
загиблих і ми це зупинили друзі
підписуйтеся на наш YouTube канал тут
багато інформації про правду що
відбувається в парламенті тримаймо стрій